[Musique]
Stansted la terre le bétail et le
petit coin de paradis du toit des Fermes Armin
eh bien
ça
ressemble à cette
coupe un peu plus sombre il y a environ 10 ans
le nouveau propriétaire un producteur céréalier a décidé
d'appliquer des biosolides municipaux pour
fertiliser les champs
c'est
des boues
biosolides municipaux  les eaux usées une
catégorie de sols amendés
ou pour le dire crûment le
fumier humain
qu'il provienne de l'
industrie des systèmes municipaux ou des déchets des fosses septiques Les
eaux usées sont traitées dans les
800 usines de traitement de la province qui purifient l'
eau autant que possible avant de
la rejeter dans les cours
le principal déchet de ce
traitement
il existe trois principales options d'élimination l'
incinération en décharge
ou son application sur
les champs agricoles les
biosolides présentent plusieurs avantages
ils sont riches en azote phosphore et en
matière organique
à quelques exceptions près ils ne sont pas autorisés
à être utilisés sur des champs qui produisent
cultures maraîchères ou vivrières
[Musique]
terres amendées Les entreprises de valorisation
font le lien entre la station d'épuration
et les champs Les
deux principales entreprises québécoises sont viridus
et dans Globe
en général ce sont elles qui sollicitent
Des agriculteurs comme Armin l'
étranger l'étranger
[Musique]
le secteur  est régi par le guide de
recyclage des matières résiduelles d'engrais
il y a des règles strictes à suivre
les agronomes embauchés par les boues Les
entreprises de valorisation s'occupent de tous
les aspects administratifs
car
[Musique]
les agronomes de l'entreprise produisent un
plan de recyclage agro-environnemental pour
l'agriculteur
ils aussi  rédiger l'avis de projet et le
remettre au ministère de l'
environnement
le gouvernement a établi des
normes de surveillance pour certaines substances toxiques
Au cours des 18 dernières
années, il s'est spécialisé dans l'agro-environnement,
environ 10% de ses clients utilisent des
biosolides,
de sorte que
les clients utilisant des biosolides sont principalement des
producteurs agricoles avec de grands champs
qui n'ont pas accès au fumier animal
à proximité
ou qui ne produisent pas assez
à cause de l'inflation dans  la guerre en
Ukraine le prix des engrais a
explosé les
boues offertes gratuitement deviennent
une option attrayante
la demande de biosolides
dépasse actuellement l'offre sur le marché
[Musique] le
printemps et l'automne sont les saisons d'épandage
des montagnes de boues s'accumulent dans les
champs
[  Musique]
depuis la route les tas attirent à peine l'
attention
vu du ciel le volume est
impressionnant
[Musique]
le ministère de l'environnement voit un
intérêt croissant pour les boues municipales
il a identifié 229 projets en 2012 et
421 en 2018 une augmentation de 45%
pourquoi
parfois la transaction  se fait
directement entre l'agriculteur et l'
agronome de l'entreprise
sans consulter un deuxième
agronome indépendant comme sylvain
apples
Stone Depot j'adore cet
épisode
le ministère de l'environnement
autorise et surveille les activités
il fixe les lignes directrices pour éviter
la contamination de l'environnement mais il
n'analyse pas les boues  avant l'
épandage l'entreprise fait que le
ministère ne contre-vérifie pas
le département enquête s'il
reçoit des plaintes du public
après l'épandage
en plus de ce processus le
département mène ses propres audits
les documents que nous avons obtenus montrent plusieurs
fautes commises par les agronomes
fausse déclaration
échantillonnage effectué  de manière inadéquate et
biaisée
niveaux excédentaires très significatifs de
nickel chrome et zinc millénaires
application à moins de 15 mètres d'une maison
application au sol à moins de 2,8 mètres d'un
fossé à
30 mètres d'une source d'eau
application au sol à 100 mètres d'un puits
utilisé pour la consommation humaine stockage de
pathogènes biasolids non conformes
en plus certains d'entre eux ont été
enregistrés lobbyistes favorisant l'application bio-solide
tout en restant agronomes
quelques décorations
y a t'il conflit d'intérêt nous avons demandé
le président de l'ordre des
agronomes étrangers
nous a envoyé une réponse complémentaire
la notion d'acceptabilité sociale doit
l'ordre attend de ses
membres qu'ils fassent preuve de prudence et qu'ils évitent à
tout prix les situations de conflit d'intérêts
sous peine de sanctions
en juillet 2022 l'ordre des agronomes
a radié un de ses membres pendant deux
mois le conseil de discipline
l'a accusé de manquements objectivement graves et
de  s'étant placé dans un conflit
d'intérêts, ses rapports, selon la décision,
étaient criblés d'émissions importantes
telles que la protection des puits des voies navigables
dans les habitations voisines était
compromise,
mais il y a autre chose que le problème
étranger
ce qu'il y a dans le fumier humain qui est répandu
sur les terres agricoles
vidéo
étrangère
à  découvrez que nous avons visité les
laboratoires de chimie environnementale de l'équipe du chercheur de l'Université
de moriale
Sebastian Soviet
étudie des composés d'
intérêt émergent, y compris ceux trouvés dans les
biosolides
la puce
étrangère
les scientifiques accordent une attention particulière aux
produits chimiques pfas d'intérêt émergent également
appelés Forever les produits chimiques
sont donc des
réactions  écosystème étranger
somme
nous avons montré les images à Saba Khan
l'avocate se spécialise en
droit international de l'environnement
son expertise est dans les lois relatives aux produits chimiques et aux déchets
actuellement le gouvernement du Québec ne sait
pratiquement rien de la présence de
pfas dans les boues d'épuration de la province
chercheurs de l'université de
Waterloo  des boues testées provenant de neuf
usines de traitement des eaux usées à travers le pays elles
contiennent toutes des pfas un tel exercice
n'a jamais été fait au Québec
est
venu sur
[musique]
pour notre enquête deux échantillons ont été
prélevés sur l'un des tas de boues du
centre du Québec qui avait une odeur nauséabonde
[Musique]
d'accord,
le taux le plus élevé parmi les échantillons était de 118
parties par milliard,
un niveau inquiétant, selon l'enquête de Sebastian
à l'étranger,
le deuxième échantillon a un
niveau de concentration de 71 parties par milliard,
c'est
avec l'aide de silvendagosh que le
chimiste a également prélevé des échantillons auprès de l'un
des agronomes.  les clients qui utilisent
des biosolides
la ferme est idéale pour l'exercice les
biosolides ont été appliqués sur des parties du
champ
les autres parties n'étaient pas
une partie du troupeau de vaches ont mangé du foin cultivé
dans un champ fertilisé avec des biosolides l'
autre n'a pas
[Musique]
les nouvelles ne sont pas  bon pour le client de civil agosh
le fumier des vaches nourries au foin sans
biosolides avait un niveau de 0,84 parties par
milliard
le fumier des vaches nourries au foin du
champ fertilisé avec des biosolides est trois
fois plus contaminé par les pfas
aujourd'hui
oh
est
downl
étranger
doit être traité avec prudence  surtout
avant de faire une hypothèse sur les
concentrations de pfas dans le lait de vache
vraiment
pas loin d'ici au sud de la frontière,
l'état du Maine a testé les pfas
dans le lait de fumier de sol et le sang
des producteurs agricoles
sur la base des résultats de cette
enquête approfondie  et jusqu'à ce qu'une meilleure façon d'
éliminer les boues soit connue,
le gouvernement a appliqué le
principe de précaution,
l'épandage des boues est maintenant strictement
interdit
et maintenant ces boues sont détournées
vers le Québec
[Musique] Les
étangs de Sanford abritent plus de 200 espèces
d'oiseaux
ils attirent les ornithologues  de tout le Maine,
nous voyons des canards colverts um Carmen mcansers bois
est fier des bassins d'aération
il gère l'usine de traitement des eaux usées de la municipalité
dans la partie sud de
l'état
ces lagunes sont utilisées pour les débits excédentaires
mais juste à côté des étangs les problèmes
s'accumulent
qui  est un gros problème il ne pouvait plus
se débarrasser des boues d'épuration à
des fins de fertilisation
même si la rétrocaveuse essaie de
maximiser l'espace la décharge
déborde
cette décharge est pleine
euh oui ces dernières années pour empêcher la
décharge de s'accumuler trop rapidement
la municipalité a investi près de 2
millions de dollars pour produire du compost à partir de
ses boues
le produit a été vendu à des agriculteurs
paysagistes des villes et des particuliers
maintenant le tas de compost ne fait que
grossir
les résultats étaient que nous avions toujours des
produits chimiques dans notre compost
nous vous montrerons à quel point il fait chaud le
compost a testé les résultats  montrent des pfas
même si les boues ont été mélangées à d'
autres matériaux, y compris le bois et Ash
Maine interdit toute utilisation de biosolides ou de
compost à base de boues d'épuration,
le directeur de l'usine et des dizaines d'autres
comme lui dans l'État sont aux prises
avec le même problème, les
boues s'accumulent et  ils doivent s'en
débarrasser
nos options sont la décharge seulement il
n'y a pas d'épandage sur les terres
et le problème avec les décharges est qu'il
n'y a pas de décharge autorisée
ici évidemment nous avons celle derrière
ce bâtiment mais c'est à pleine capacité
une lettre adressée à l'un d'entre eux
dont nous avons obtenu une copie
en dit plus sur les impacts de cette
décision
Casella, l'un des plus grands transformateurs de biosolides américains,
affirme que la nouvelle réglementation du Maine
l'obligera à développer de nouveaux marchés pour
son compost,
y compris le marché canadien
[Musique]
après l'interdiction dans le Maine Andre  Russo
a reçu une proposition du Québec
et Globe nous a contacté il y a environ un mois
avec un fort intérêt pour nos biosolides
donc il y a un gros besoin de compost au
Québec et Globe serait une bouée de sauvetage pour
nous car nous
aurions un point final pour  ces résidus
l'autre Lifeline est RMI
l'entreprise est un partenaire américain d'
alors Globe également spécialisé dans la
valorisation des biosolides
ils arrivent à New Hampton New
Hampshire où se trouve notre installation si vous
regardez le 93 et ​​nous sommes en plein milieu
et  puis ça monte euh au Canada les
principales usines de traitement des eaux usées
détournent maintenant leurs boues vers le
centre de traitement du New Hampshire
maintenant nous ne faisons pas le transport vers le Canada
notre entreprise
euh l'a sous-traité et donc
ils sont responsables du transport
et de la traversée  la frontière et la conformité
pour la livraison
avec les informations que nous avons obtenues nous avons
pu localiser le camion d'une
entreprise de transport canadienne un sous-traitant d'
onglub arrivant du New Hampshire
au poste frontière à Stansted
dans le cas de notre um
trajet actuel vers le Canada nous'  Je fais
peut-être quatre à cinq charges par semaine,
selon la semaine,
chaque charge est de 30 tonnes de
matériaux dont nous avons détourné une partie
du matériau vers le Canada,
vous savez que cela va être appliqué sur les terres et
profiter aux agriculteurs du Canada,
euh c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
c'est ici à Buri dans les cantons de l'est
que le camion que nous avons suivi déverse
sa cargaison
merci
sur Globe de nous ouvrir les portes de son
côté compostage
contrairement à ce que rapporte le RMI et Globe
nous assure que les boues municipales américaines
ne sont pas épandues sur les champs agricoles
um
étrangers
qui se retrouve ailleurs dans l'
environnement
étranger étranger
[Musique]
celui que nous avons testé qui a montré jusqu'à 118
parties par milliard de pfas
le matériau a été épandu et le
panneau routier indique que ses boues de papeterie
sont censées provenir du Québec
selon onglope
[Musique]
rien d'illégal car au Canada et au
Québec il n'y a pas de loi régissant la
présence de pfas dans les biosolides
c'est la
population
dans ce contexte anglobe
s'auto-réglemente
un laboratoire certifié qu'il embauche
teste systématiquement les boues américaines pour 22
types de pfas
l'entreprise teste régulièrement les
concentrations de pfas  pour la [ __ ] québécoise,
je m'appelle
[Music]
lorsque les niveaux dépassent leurs normes
anglobe s'assure que le matériel n'est pas
importé au Canada
une
autorité est
[Music]
ppb ou parties par milliard
avant l'interdiction le gouvernement principal
réglementait deux types de pfas
pfoa était  limité à 2,5 ppb
et pfos était limité à 5,2 ppbs Les
résultats de l'enquête de Sebastian sur les boues que
nous avons testées d'onglobe montrent qu'elles sont
cinq fois plus concentrées en pfoa et
six fois plus contaminées que les pfos
que dans les anciennes normes principales
dans un e-mail onglobe dit qu'ils  sont
surpris par ces résultats parce que leurs
propres données ne supportent pas cette conclusion,
que les boues proviennent du Québec ou
du Maine Louis Côté soutient que la
récupération reste une option verte
surprise étrangère
[Musique]
le pont Ambassador le
lien Detroit Windsor
la route des biosolides  les pistes entre
le Michigan et l'Ontario
c'est comme 70 000 tonnes sèches ce sont des
tonnes américaines mais ouais
c'est allé au Canada
Denise trabitch pointer est la
spécialiste des substances toxiques pour le Sierra
Club au Michigan
selon le groupe environnemental
plus de 2 300 camions de boues
à travers l'Ontario  frontière chaque année,
c'est l'équivalent de six camions par
jour si vous étiez canadien, comment
réagiriez-vous?  curieux
de savoir ce qui se passe dans mon pays, le
Michigan est l'un des principaux
États industriels des États-Unis. C'est
là que les pfa sont originaires.
Il y a des opérations de raffinage du pétrole.
États-Unis et certainement dans le Michigan et le
Maine et certains des États du nord-est. Le
Maine est jusqu'à présent le seul État à avoir
totalement interdit l'épandage de
boues.
20 parties par milliard d'épandage de pfos sur les terres
sont autorisés,
ce qui est quatre fois plus élevé que la
limite de seuil pré-bande du Maine
et c'est la norme sur les besoins de glub
pour le Québec
UE
euh [
Musique] merci [
Musique]
J'ai travaillé dans j'ai rempli de peinture j'ai fait ça
avant  elle a commencé à suivre les biosols pour
le Sierra Club Denise trabitch pointer
a travaillé 42 ans pour un émetteur de pfas
le géant américain de la chimie DuPont
Dupont a été condamné par les tribunaux américains
au milieu des années 2000 pour avoir retenu
des informations sur la toxicité des
produits utilisés dans Teflon
[Musique]
ce  pfas Saga lui a fait faire un 180 complet.
ouais c'est marrant parce que j'avais même des
amis à moi de DuPont sur Facebook qui
ont dit ah tu as rejoint le côté obscur et j'ai
dit bon c'est peut-être l'inverse
au Québec qu'on voulait avoir  des explications
du ministère de l'environnement
tant le ministre Benoit chaget que le
ministère ont refusé nos demandes d'interviews
cependant avant notre enquête un
responsable du ministère a répondu
aux questions de nos collègues à
supposer concernant la possibilité que
des boues traversent la frontière
[Musique]
car le
Globe étranger le  l'entreprise refuse de divulguer
les quantités qu'elle importe au Québec
donc ce
n'est pas seulement je suis
sûr que le Massachusetts le Vermont et New York
exportent aussi des biosolides au Québec
le gouvernement seulement des données très partielles sur
les volumes de biosol sont des obligations importées
[Musique]
selon le ministère de la
environnement les points d'origine des
biosolides municipaux sont conservés dans les
dossiers de l'exploitant
Québec doit donc frapper à la porte
des entreprises pour savoir d'où
viennent ces biosolides et quelle quantité exacte de
boues ou de compost est importée
des États-Unis
unglub veut collaborer et dit  il
aimerait voir un
cadre réglementaire
étranger mieux défini
pour ceux qui ont des bottes sur le terrain il est
temps d'agir à l'
étranger
pendant ce temps,
Ottawa prévoit de publier un rapport sur l'
état des pfas en 2023
le gouvernement fédéral peut restreindre l'
utilisation des pfas
est
étranger
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
Trésors [
Musique] [
Musique]
le pfis est
[Musique]